Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
Both:
"POURQUOI PAS L'EAU D'AMANDE?"
PERFECT!
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WHAT'S DIRTIER -- YOUR CELLPHONE
OR A PUBLIC TOILET?
DISGUSTING.
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY
AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
LORI, WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU CREATED A SALES FORCE?
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT I DO.
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
THIS IS NOT
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
NO, BUT IT'S JUST --
IT'S DIFFERENT.
IT'S STILL A RIP-OFF.
I SMELL JAIL TIME.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT
FROM WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
[ French accent ]
BONJOUR. I'M DEBORAH MENIANE.
AND I'M DAVID MENIANE.
AND WE LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE THE OWNERS
OF VICTORIA'S KITCHEN.
DAVID AND I GREW UP TOGETHER
IN PARIS.
OUR PARENTS
WERE BEST FRIENDS.
WE WENT TO
THE SAME HIGH SCHOOL.
EVEN THOUGH
WE STARTED AS FRIENDS,
I'VE ALWAYS KNOWN, DEEP DOWN,
THAT WE WOULD END UP TOGETHER.
WE'RE MADE
FOR EACH OTHER.
SHE'S COOKING IN THIS ONE.
SHE'S PROBABLY MAKING IT.
MY GRANDMOTHER VICTORIA
USED TO MAKE OUR PRODUCT
IN HER KITCHEN,
AND EVERY SUNDAY,
WE WOULD GO TO HER HOUSE
AND CONSUME IT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
ALORS, ALORS!
WE MADE OUR PRODUCT FOR
OUR FRIENDS WHEN THEY CAME OVER.
THEY LOVED IT SO MUCH,
THEY KEPT ASKING US TO MAKE MORE
FOR THEM TO TAKE HOME.
AND, VOILà,
OUR PRODUCT WAS BORN,
AND WE OWE IT ALL
TO GRANDMA.
CHEERS.
David: IN THE FOOD-AND-BEVERAGE
INDUSTRY,
THE COMPETITORS
ARE REALLY BIG.
AND BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES
THE BIG PLAYERS HAVE,
WE HAVE TO BE INNOVATIVE
TO MAKE IT WORK.
WE RISKED EVERYTHING
FOR THE BUSINESS.
WE INVESTED
ALL OUR LIFE SAVINGS,
AND WE BOTH QUIT OUR JOBS.
IT'S MY GRANDMOTHER'S NAME,
IT'S MY GRANDMOTHER'S FACE,
IT'S OUR ENTIRE LIVES,
SO I REALLY NEED IT TO SUCCEED.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS DAVID,
AND THIS IS MY WIFE, DEBORAH.
WE'RE FROM PARIS, FRANCE,
AND WE'RE THE FOUNDERS
OF VICTORIA'S KITCHEN.
TODAY WE'RE SEEKING
AN INVESTMENT OF $200,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
SO, I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
GREW UP WITH A GRANDMOTHER
WHO LIKED TO COOK,
RIGHT?
AND MY GRANDMOTHER VICTORIA
IS NO EXCEPTION.
BUT UNLIKE
AMERICAN GRANDMOTHERS
WHO LIKE TO MAKE LEMONADE
OR SWEET ICED TEA,
SHE MAKES
AN AMAZING ALMOND WATER.
IT'S LIGHT, IT'S CRISP,
AND IT'S SO REFRESHING.
SO, WHEN DAVID AND I
MOVED TO THE U.S.,
WE PACKED THIS ONE-OF-A-KIND
FRENCH RECIPE WITH US.
WE STARTED MAKING IT,
AND OUR FRIENDS
COULD NOT GET ENOUGH OF IT.
WE HAD ALWAYS WANTED
TO START A BUSINESS TOGETHER,
SO ONE DAY, WE LOOKED
AT EACH OTHER AND WE SAID...
Both:
"POURQUOI PAS L'EAU D'AMANDE?"
"WHY NOT ALMOND WATER?"
[ LAUGHS ]
OUR ALMOND WATER
IS ALL-NATURAL,
VEGAN, SOY-FREE, DAIRY-FREE,
GMO-FREE, GLUTEN-FREE,
BUT MOST OF ALL,
IT IS THAT PERFECT TREAT
THAT WILL MAKE YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE LOUNGING
IN THE FRESHLY CUT GRASS
IN THE SOUTH OF FRANCE.
SO, WHO'S READY
TO STEP INTO...
Both:
VICTORIA'S KITCHEN...
...AND JOIN OUR FAMILY?
CAN WE TRY IT?
OF COURSE.
HOW MANY CALORIES
PER BOTTLE?
SO, THE ORIGINAL HAS
110 CALORIES PER BOTTLE.
THAT'S IT?
THE COCONUT HAS
100 CALORIES PER BOTTLE.
SO, WE HAVE TWO FLAVORS.
ALMOND WATER ORIGINAL
IS THE COMBINATION
OF ALMOND, VANILLA,
AND ROSE.
AND THEN WE HAVE
ALMOND AND COCONUT.
Herjavec: TRèS BIEN.
MERCI.
[ CORCORAN LAUGHS ]
YEAH.
MERCI, ROBERT.
OH, WOW. THAT'S VERY GOOD.
DAVID, IT'S FANTASTIC.
SERIOUSLY.
THANK YOU.
IT'S VERY SWEET.
SO, IT'S BASED ON
MY GRANDMOTHER'S RECIPE.
THAT'S YOUR GRANDMOTHER
IN THE PICTURE?
THAT'S VICTORIA. SHE'S
ALL OVER THE PLACE WITH US.
YES. [ CHUCKLES ]
DAVID, TELL ME
ABOUT ALMOND WATER.
IS THIS A COMMON DRINK
IN FRANCE?
SO, IT'S VERY POPULAR
IN EUROPE --
IN ITALY, IN SICILY,
IN GREECE, IN TURKEY...
SEE IF YOU WANT
THIS ONE.
...IN MIDDLE EASTERN
COUNTRIES.
WAS IT A SPECIALTY DRINK,
LIKE A DESSERT THING?
IT'S A FAMILY DRINK.
IT'S A PICNIC DRINK.
YOU KNOW,
I GO TO MY GRANDMOTHER'S,
SHE MAKES APPLE CAKE
AND ALMOND WATER.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
WE HAVE IN THE SHARK TANK
WITH ALL OF THE BEVERAGE DEALS
THAT COMES IN HERE,
IN THE END, DISTRIBUTION SEEMS
TO BE THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE --
GETTING SHELF SPACE AWAY
FROM GIANT COMPANIES WHO OWN IT.
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE THERE?
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
FIRST YEAR --
$160,000.
OKAY.
SECOND YEAR --
$330,000.
AND THIR--
AND WE'RE
IN OUR THIRD YEAR.
RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE AT ABOUT $210,000,
$220,000
FOR 8 MONTHS.
AND, DAVID, HOW ARE SELLING IT?
WHAT STORES?
SO, WE SELL MOSTLY TO NATURAL
AND SPECIALTY FOOD STORES
AND INDEPENDENT GROCERY STORES
FOR 60 CENTS,
AND THEN I SELL IT FOR $1.10.
IT'S 45% MARGIN.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN
IN AMERICA?
14 YEARS? YEAH.
14 YEARS, YES.
SO, I MOVED OUT HERE,
I WAS 17 YEARS OLD,
DIDN'T SPEAK
A WORD OF ENGLISH,
AND MY DREAM WAS,
"LET ME CREATE SOMETHING.
LET ME START SOME--
SOMETHING FROM SCRATCH."
SO, I HAD
A HIGH-PAYING JOB BEFORE,
AND I LEFT
TO DO THIS FULL TIME.
WE WANTED TO BUILD A BUSINESS,
SO WE TOOK ALL OUR SAVINGS
AND WE INVESTED IT
IN VICTORIA'S KITCHEN.
HOW MUCH?
ABOUT $250,000...
WOW.
...WHICH IS EVERYTHING
WE HAD, SO --
THAT'S ALL IN.
ALL IN. IT'S ALL IN.
IT'S ALL IN. YEAH.
LOOK -- LOOK,
I JUST -- I WANT TO GO BACK --
HOW MANY STORES ARE YOU IN?
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
ABOUT 800?
ABOUT 800.
NATIONWIDE. YEAH.
NAME A COUPLE?
DO YOU HAVE WHOLE FOODS?
WHOLE FOOD,
NEW SEASONS...
OH, YOU DO?
...ANDRONICO'S, LUNARDI'S.
WHOLE FOODS IS NOT REALLY
OUR TARGET MARKET.
WHY?
IT SEEMS PERFECT.
I WOULD THINK
IT'S PERFECT.
BECAUSE --
IT'S -- IT'S ACTUALLY
NOT THAT PERFECT
BECAUSE IT'S A REALLY --
IT'S A MARKET THAT'S
REALLY TARGETED ON HEALTH --
MEANING, IT'S NOT --
BECAUSE IT HAS
15 GRAMS OF SUGAR.
EVERYTHING ELSE
IS FUNCTIONAL.
IT DOESN'T HAVE
A VITAMIN.
IT'S NOT GONNA MAKE YOU GROW
WINGS OR, YOU KNOW, RUN FASTER.
WELL, NO. NO, BUT COME ON.
NO, NO, REALLY, IT COMES DOWN
TO THE SUGAR, RIGHT?
HOW MANY GRAMS OF SUGAR
IS IN A SODA,
AS OPPOSED TO ONE OF THESE?
IT COULD GO DOUBLE.
I'LL GIVE YOU --
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
UM, THE TOP-SELLING LEMONADE
IN THE UNITED STATES,
THERE IS 56 GRAMS OF SUGAR
IN 16 OUNCES.
YEAH, BUT BETTER -- BETTER
THAN BAD DOESN'T MAKE IT GOOD.
NO, BUT IT'S JUST --
IT'S DIFFERENT.
WHAT'S THE NEXT STEP?
THERE'S A FEW WAYS
WE CAN GROW THE COMPANY.
ONE WAY
IS ADDING MORE SKUs.
SECOND --
MEANING, ADDING --
ADDING MORE FLAVORS
AND MORE PRODUCTS.
HOW ABOUT MORE STORES?
HOW ARE YOU GONNA DO THAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
BEFORE GETTING TO MORE STORES,
I WANT TO SELL MORE PRODUCT
TO MY EXISTING STORES.
I WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE MARKETS THAT I HAVE.
SO, WHAT'S THE NEXT FLAVOR?
WHY DON'T WE SHOW YOU OUR NEW --
OUR NEXT PRODUCT.
PERFECT!
YES! DO THAT.
ALL RIGHT, SO, THIS --
THESE ARE SAMPLES.
WE WANTED
TO TRY SOMETHING NEW.
WE HAVE DISTRIBUTORS.
WE HAVE RETAILERS THAT LIKE US.
DAVID, TELL ME WHAT THIS IS.
Corcoran:
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS IS AN ORGANIC,
LOW-CALORIE LEMONADE...
OH, LOW-CALORIE!
SHOCKING!
...WITH
COLD-PRESSED GINGER.
THIS IS REALLY GOOD.
WE HAVE
ORGANIC LEMON JUICE,
ORGANIC, COLD-PRESSED
GINGER JUICE,
AND THEN
CAYENNE PEPPER.
Deborah:
BUT IT'S MADE WITH AGAVE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME
IS YOU WENT LOWER-CALORIE,
SO IT'S SORT OF LIKE
YOU TOOK --
IT SEEMS TO ME
LIKE YOU TOOK ADVICE.
YES. WE LISTEN TO
WHAT PEOPLE HAVE TO SAY.
MM.
I'M NOT GONNA TELL THEM
WHAT THEY LIKE.
YOU TELL ME WHAT YOU LIKE,
AND I'LL MAKE IT HAPPEN.
Corcoran:
YOU GAVE US FIGURES EARLIER.
YOU SAID YEAR 1,
YOU DID $160,000.
YEAR 2, YOU DID $330,000.
SO FAR THIS YEAR, $210,000.
IF I MULTIPLY THAT OUT,
THAT MEANS YOUR SALES --
YOU'LL END THE YEAR
WITH ROUGHLY $280,000,
AS OPPOSED TO $330,000
LAST YEAR.
ARE SALES DOWN?
WHY HAVE YOUR SALES
GONE DOWN SO MUCH?
SO, WE HAD A THIRD SKU,
SO WE HAD AN ALMOND WATER
WITH LICORICE-MINT.
IT WAS OUR FAVORITE SKU --
MY FAVORITE SKU.
NOT HERE, RIGHT?
NOW, WE DISCONTINUED IT.
SO, WE SOLD ABOUT $40,000
OF THAT LAST YEAR,
SO I DON'T HAVE THAT
THIS YEAR.
SO YOUR SALES DROPPED BY $40,000
BECAUSE OF THAT ONE PRODUCT?
YEAH, THAT ONE SKU.
OKAY.
RIGHT NOW,
WE SELL ABOUT $25,000 --
$25,000 TO $30,000
A MONTH.
THAT'S WITH NO SALES FORCE,
NO MERCHANDISING.
LISTEN,
I LIKE YOUR PACKAGING.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY.
IT TASTES DELICIOUS.
BUT I FEEL YOU DO HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO --
TO DO IN CHANGING
THIS PRODUCT
SO THAT IT WILL BECOME
A BETTER FIT
FOR PLACES LIKE WHOLE FOODS --
I THINK YOU'LL GET THERE --
BUT FOR THAT REASON,
RIGHT NOW, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE
THAT SPECIFIC PRODUCT,
BUT YOU LIKE ME,
YOU LIKE MY WIFE,
YOU LIKE MY PACKAGING,
YOU PARTNER UP WITH US,
AND I'LL LISTEN
TO FEEDBACK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'VE PROVEN THE FACT
THAT I CAN LISTEN.
DAVID, I INVESTED IN A
SODA COMPANY CALLED CHILL SODA.
I WALKED THE ROAD OVER TWO YEARS
OF HOW HARD IT IS
TO GET THE SPACE
IN THE GROCERY STORE
TO MAKE THIS BRAND HAPPEN.
I DON'T THINK THE AMOUNT
YOU'RE ASKING, $200,000,
IS ANYTHING THAT'S GONNA
APPROACH WHAT YOU NEED.
SO I'M OUT.
DAVID, YOUR DRIVE IS --
IS TANGIBLE.
IT'S INCREDIBLE HOW MOTIVATED
BOTH OF YOU ARE.
AND, UH...HERE'S THE PART
I DON'T LIKE.
YOU ALMOST LISTEN TOO MUCH.
YOU -- YOU --
WHEN YOU'RE THIS SMALL,
YOU CAN'T ASSUME YOUR CUSTOMERS
KNOW WHAT THEY WANT.
SOMETIMES, WHEN YOU'RE STARTING
A BRAND-NEW MARKET,
YOU HAVE TO TELL THE CUSTOMERS
WHAT THEY WANT.
I JUST DON'T LIKE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE TELLING ME
YOU'RE GONNA LISTEN TO
THE CUSTOMERS ALL THE TIME.
I THINK YOU'RE --
WE LISTEN FOR TWEAKS.
I'M NOT GONNA TELL THEM, "I WANT
THIS PRODUCT," AND MAKE IT.
BUT IF PEOPLE TELL ME
IT'S A LITTLE TOO SWEET,
THEN I'M GONNA
CUT THE SUGAR BY 20%.
OR IF WE HEAR A LOT THAT,
YOU KNOW, SUGAR --
[ French accent ]
YEAH, BUT, "SACRé BLEU,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO!"
SACRé BLEU!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING, ROBERT?
SO WE LAUNCHED
OUR ALMOND WATER COCONUT.
[ Normal voice ]
UH...I'M OUT.
O'Leary: NORMALLY,
WHAT I WOULD DO IS --
IS EVISCERATE YOU ON VALUATION,
BUT BECAUSE I'M A NICE GUY,
I'M NOT GONNA BOTHER,
BUT YOUR ASK IS RIDICULOUS.
UM, YOU'RE NOT WORTH
A MILLION BUCKS.
I WANT TO PARTNER
WITH YOU.
IF YOU THINK
IT'S A LITTLE TOO HIGH,
YOU TELL ME WHAT YOU NEED
TO MAKE IT WORK,
AND MAYBE
WE CAN MAKE IT WORK.
I-I -- MY -- MY MOST VALUABLE
RESOURCE IS MY TIME.
I'D HAVE TO SPEND
A LOT OF TIME WITH YOU,
AND I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
I'M OUT.
MARK, I-I KNOW
WE'RE SMALL...
[ CHUCKLES ]
...AND I KNOW, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE MADE MISTAKES,
BUT WE'RE GROWING.
WE HAVE A GOOD PRODUCT.
IF IT HAS SUGAR
AND IT'S A PROBLEM FOR YOU,
WE CAN MAKE A KIDS' LINE,
YOU KNOW?
YEAH, B-- THE PROBLEM IS --
I'LL TELL YOU --
BUT IT'S SELLING.
PEOPLE LIKE IT.
I-I GET THAT, HONESTLY,
BUT YOU'RE STARTING TO COME
ACROSS AS DESPERATE, RIGHT?
SERIOUSLY.
NO, I-I --
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING AGGRESSIVE...
YEAH?
...AND A GREAT SALESPERSON
AND THEN SAYING YES
TO EVERY QUESTION
THAT A POTENTIAL INVESTOR ASKS.
I'M NOT -- I HAVEN'T SAID YES
TO ANYTHING YET.
YES, YOU HAVE.
YES, YOU'VE SAID
TO EVERYTHING, YOU'VE SAID YES.
YOU'VE SAID YES
TO EVERYTHING.
[ French accent ]
"YOU DON'T LIKE THE SUGAR,
WE PUT IN THE SUGAR.
YOU DON'T LIKE THE PACKAGING,
WE CHANGE THE PACKAGING."
Greiner:
"WE CAN MAKE IT WORK."
[ LAUGHS ]
NO, I'M NOT GONNA
CUT THE SUGAR COMPLETELY,
BUT, YOU KNOW, IF YOU THINK
IT'S A LITTLE TOO SWEET --
[ Normal voice ]
YEAH, THERE YOU GO!
I -- CAN SELL.
I CAN --
IF YOU'RE PART
OF THE COMPANY,
WE HAVE TO LISTEN TO
YOUR INPUT, TOO.
YOU CAN'T PLEASE EVERYBODY.
NO, YOU CAN'T
PLEASE EVERYBODY.
GUYS...IF YOU HAD WALKED IN HERE
WITH A ZERO-CALORIE,
I WOULD HAVE BEEN
ALL OVER IT.
I'M OUT.
OH, DAVID, DEBORAH, MERCI.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SHARKS.
MERCI BEAUCOUP.
MERCI. MERCI BEAUCOUP.
HOPE YOU ENJOYED IT.
MERCI.
I WISH THERE WAS A WAY.
EH?
IT'S OKAY.
WE CAME TO AMERICA, WE DIDN'T
SPEAK A WORD OF ENGLISH.
WE BUILT A BUSINESS
FROM SCRATCH.
WE WENT INTO THE SHARK TANK,
AND WE GOT
SOME GREAT POSITIVE FEEDBACK
FROM ALL THE SHARKS.
THAT'S AMAZING FOR US.
THAT'S AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE.
AND EVEN THOUGH
WE DIDN'T GET A DEAL,
IT'S STILL
VERY ENCOURAGING.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A BETTER, GREENER DESIGN
OF A TO-GO ACCESSORY.
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M JEN.
AND I'M NED.
AND WE ARE THE FOUNDERS
OF GreenBox.
WE ARE HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU
FOR A $300,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR A
10% EQUITY STAKE IN OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, BASED ON
OUR CONSUMPTIONS...
OH, MY GOD.
IT'S PIZZA.
Corcoran:
IT'S ALL RESEARCH.
DON'T WORRY. DON'T WORRY.
TAKE A BREATH.
BASED -- SORRY, GUYS.
SHARKS,
BASED ON OUR RESEARCH...
JEN, STOP
MAKING HIM NERVOUS.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, MY GOD.
DON'T WORRY. IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT MOMENT IN YOUR LIFE.
SHUT UP, KEVIN.
EXACTLY!
WHY DON'T YOU REBOOT?
STEP BACK AND REBOOT.
Greiner: DO YOU WANT TO TRY IT
AGAIN? YEAH, DO IT AGAIN.
NED, IF YOU WANT IT DONE RIGHT,
GET A WOMAN TO DO IT.
Cuban: NO, YOU GOT
A RIGHT TO GO AGAIN.
REBOOT, REBOOT.
YEAH? ALL RIGHT.
[ SIGHS ] OKAY.
HELLO, SHARKS.
Sorry.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOW I'M NERVOUS.
OH, MY GOD.
HE -- I COULDN'T
SAY IT, EITHER.
OKAY, NEXT!
Ned: WAIT, LET'S DO THIS.
ALL RIGHT.
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M JEN.
AND I'M NED, AND WE ARE
THE FOUNDERS OF GreenBox.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU
FOR A $300,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR A
10% EQUITY STAKE IN OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, OUR RESEARCH SHOWS THAT,
BASED ON CONSUMPTION,
PEOPLE LIKE PIZZA
EVEN MORE THAN THEY LIKE SEX.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT THE ONLY PROBLEM
WITH PIZZA
IS THAT PIZZA BOXES
ARE JUST TOO CUMBERSOME.
ALL OF US HAVE STRUGGLED
TO CRAM AN ENTIRE PIZZA BOX
INTO THE FRIDGE
AND THEN INTO THE GARBAGE CAN.
IT'S AN AGE-OLD PROBLEM
THAT'S NEVER BEEN FIXED.
OUR FLAGSHIP PRODUCT,
THE GreenBox,
OFFERS A REVOLUTIONARY,
ECO-FRIENDLY SOLUTION
FOR ALL THESE PROBLEMS.
SO, WHAT IS A GreenBox?
THE GreenBox
IS A PIZZA BOX
MADE FROM 100%
RECYCLED MATERIAL.
THE TOP OF THE BOX
TEARS OFF
AND BREAKS DOWN
INTO FOUR STURDY PLATES.
THIS ELIMINATES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL DISPOSABLE PLATES,
AND IT NEGATES THE NEED
FOR CLEANING UP,
WHICH NO ONE EVER ENJOYS.
BUT WE'RE NOT DONE THERE.
THE BOTTOM OF THE BOX
FOLDS INTO A HANDY STORAGE
CONTAINER FOR LEFTOVERS.
THIS ELIMINATES THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL STORAGE MATERIALS
LIKE ALUMINUM FOIL
AND PLASTIC WRAP.
IT FITS NEATLY
IN THE FRIDGE.
Herjavec: OH!
Corcoran:
WOW! NICELY DONE.
AND WHEN
YOU'RE DONE EATING...
Cuban: THAT'S COOL.
Greiner: VERY CLEVER.
...IT FITS
IN THE GARBAGE CAN.
Ned: IT'S SIMPLE,
IT'S ECO-FRIENDLY,
AND IT HAS MASS APPEAL.
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S READY
FOR A SLICE OF THE PIE?
WE ALL ARE.
WE ALL ARE, YEAH.
[ JEN CHUCKLES ]
THERE YOU GO.
Herjavec: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THERE YOU GO, LORI.
AND, MARK,
WE DID NOT FORGET ABOUT YOU.
THIS IS
GLUTEN-FREE PIZZA.
I LIKE IT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT,
HERE'S THE STORAGE CONTAINER.
PERFECTO.
JEN, IT'S A FANTASTIC IDEA.
NEVER SEEN SOMETHING SO CLEVER
FOR THE PIZZA BOX.
BUT HERE'S THE CHALLENGE --
WHO ARE YOU GONNA SELL IT TO?
WE SELL TO DISTRIBUTORS
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
OUR BUSINESS MODEL, FROM
DAY ONE, WAS A DUAL STRATEGY.
NUMBER ONE,
PROVE OUT THE CONCEPT.
WE WANTED
TO SHOW THE WORLD
THAT THIS IS
A VIABLE PIZZA BOX,
IT HAS
STRUCTURE INTEGRITY,
THAT CUSTOMERS
WILL ACTUALLY LIKE IT,
AND THEN MOVE TO
A LICENSING MODEL.
WE'VE ACHIEVED PHASE ONE.
TELL US HOW YOU THINK --
WHY YOU THINK
YOU'VE ACHIEVED PHASE 1.
WE HAVE DISTRIBUTORS
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
OUR LARGEST CUSTOMER
IS WHOLE FOODS.
WE'RE IN
HALF THE REGIONS.
REALLY?
IS THERE A PATENT ON THIS?
YES, WE HAVE A FULL UTILITY
PATENT. IT'S FULLY ISSUED.
HOW MANY PIZZA BOXES
HAVE YOU SOLD IN YOUR CHANNEL?
DIRECT SALES --
OVER 10 MILLION.
10 MILLION PIZZA BOXES?
YES, AND OVER --
THROUGH LICENSING,
WE'VE SOLD WAY OVER 10 MILLION.
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES
LAST YEAR?
$1.7 MILLION LAST YEAR.
GOOD FOR YOU.
THAT'S AWESOME.
THAT'S VERY GOOD.
Herjavec:
THAT'S AWESOME.
JEN, IF I WAS DOMINO'S,
HOW MUCH MORE WOULD THEY PAY
FOR THIS MUCH BETTER BOX?
A FRACTION OF A PENNY.
I'M A SHAREHOLDER OF A COMPANY
CALLED BOSTON PIZZA.
YES.
HAS 650 LOCATIONS.
MM-HMM.
ALL RIGHT?
I BROUGHT THEM A SIMILAR IDEA --
NOT AS CREATIVE, ACTUALLY --
AND IT WAS ONLY GOING TO BE
A FRACTION OF A PENNY.
AND GEORGE, THE ACCOUNTANT,
SAID TO ME,
"IS IT GOING TO HELP ME SELL
ONE MORE PIZZA?"
AND THEN IT WAS ALSO
AN ECO-FRIENDLY THING,
THE -- THE LICENSER SAID BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE GONNA FEEL BETTER
ABOUT THE BOX BECAUSE
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND THEN GEORGE SAID,
"THEN I HAVE TO SPEND
A COMMUNICATION CAMPAIGN
"TO EXPLAIN
WHAT I'VE DONE WITH THE BOX,
"AND THAT COSTS ME MORE MONEY.
I HATE IT.
TELL ME HOW I CAN SAVE A CENT,
NOT INCREASE MY COSTS."
IF YOU LOOK AT A COMPANY
LIKE PIZZA HUT,
LIKE DOMINO'S,
LIKE PAPA JOHNS,
THEY SPEND MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN MARKETING.
AND SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE VIRAL LEVEL OF INTEREST
IN OUR PRODUCT,
YOU WOULD NOT HAVE
TO EVEN PUT TOGETHER
A HUGE MARKETING CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S A TOUGH SALE
WHEN YOU'RE SELLING MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF PIZZAS.
ONE HALF OF ONE CENT PER BOX
ACROSS 100 MILLION PI-PIZZAS
IS A LOT OF MONEY.
I'M OUT.
O'Leary: CAN WE FOCUS
ON THE BIG OPPORTUNITY?
LET'S PICK ANY ONE.
LET'S GO DOMINO'S.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PIZZAS
A QUARTER.
HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE
TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT ANY DEAL?
NO, WE -- WE HAVE NOT HAD ACCESS
TO THE RIGHT PEOPLE THERE.
WE'VE RESPONDED TO THE DEMAND
THAT WE'VE HAD.
I ACTUALLY KNOW THE GUYS THERE.
I MEAN, BUT --
SO COME ON BOARD.
WELL, YOU'RE NEVER GONNA MAKE
A LOT OF MONEY
UNLESS YOU CAN SELL
100 MILLION BOXES.
AND WE CAN. THIS --
SO PUT YOUR MONEY
WHERE YOUR MOUTH IS.
O'Leary: NO.
WELL, YOU SOUND LIKE YOU HAVE
A LOT OF EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA.
HE THINKS HE HAS EXPERTISE
IN EVERYTHING.
[ CHUCKLES ]
O'Leary:
AND THE PROBLEM IS, HE DOES.
AND HE'S BEEN IN EVERY BUSINESS
IN THE WORLD.
I'LL MAKE --
LOOK, I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER,
BUT IT'S SO CLEAR ON WHAT
THE PATH IS, AND IT'S BINARY,
AND IT'S COMPLETELY CONTINGENT
ON GETTING ONE OF THE MAJORS
TO -- TO LICENSE THIS
'CAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
I'D EVER MAKE ANY MONEY.
I'LL MAKE THE CALLS.
I KNOW I'M GETTING MY CALLS
RETURNED, OKAY?
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'LL EVER
ACCEPT THE PREMISE
THAT YOU HAVE IN PLACE,
BUT I'LL GET THE MEETINGS.
IF WE CAN ACHIEVE A LICENSE
DEAL, I'LL GIVE YOU $300,000.
AND YOU'RE GONNA GIVE ME 10% OF
THE COMPANY AFTER IT'S SIGNED,
AND I'M GOING TO GET
THE FIRST $300,000 BACK
FROM THE ROYALTY STREAM
ON THAT ONE DEAL.
SO, IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
HE GIVES YOU $300,000,
YOU PAY HIM BACK, AND AFTER
HE'S PAID BACK, HE OWNS 10%.
BUT IF HE DOESN'T DO THAT,
YOU GET NOTHING.
RIGHT,
BUT YOU HAVE NOTHING NOW.
SO, ROBERT AND I ARE GOING
TO MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT.
KEVIN HAS MADE AN OFFER
OF $300,000 AS A LOAN
FOR 10% EQUITY
FOR THE FUNCTIONAL-PIZZA-BOX
COMPANY GreenBox.
HOWEVER, IT'S CONTINGENT
ON MAKING A DEAL
WITH A MAJOR PIZZA COMPANY.
BUT ROBERT AND LORI
MAY HAVE A COMPETING OFFER.
SO, ROBERT AND I ARE GOING
TO MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I DO AGREE WITH KEVIN
ON ONE ASPECT.
IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME TO AGREE
WITH KEVIN ON ANYTHING,
SO I HAVE A HARD TIME
GETTING THAT OUT.
AND HE'S ALWAYS RIGHT.
WHAT CAN YOU DO?
IT -- IT IS BINARY.
AS AN INVESTOR,
WE REALLY WANT TO GO BOOM.
WE WANT TO SCALE IT UP.
AND I THINK YOU AGREE
THAT TO SCALE IT UP,
YOU'VE GOT TO GET IN FRONT
OF A LARGE PIZZA COMPANY.
THE ONE THING WE'VE LEARNED
IN SIX SEASONS --
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE A SHARK
ON YOUR TEAM.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND IT'S BETTER
TO HAVE TWO.
YES.
RIGHT, AND WE CAN ALL
GET A CALL ANSWERED
FROM ONE OF
THE MAJOR PIZZA COMPANIES.
OUR DEAL IS CONTINGENT
ON ONE OF THE LARGE PIZZA
COMPANIES COMING ON BOARD.
BUT THAT'S JUST A BIG --
WE FEEL CONFIDENT
WE'LL MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
YEAH, AND WE THINK
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
WE'LL GIVE YOU
THE $300,000 FOR 30%.
OUCH.
Cuban: OH.
Greiner: BUT WE WILL
BE WITH YOU THE WHOLE WAY.
OUCH.
THAT'S A LOT OF EQUITY.
WE FEEL VERY CONFIDENT
THAT WE WILL GET YOU INTO ONE OF
THOSE MAJOR PIZZA CHAINS.
SO YOU HAVE ONE DEAL FOR 10%,
ONE DEAL FOR 30%?
HOW COULD YOU
EVEN COMPARE THEM?
BUT YOU HAVE TO
PAY HIM BACK.
HERE'S HOW
I SEE THE PRODUCT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S OBVIOUS
THAT THIS IS A SPECIAL BOX,
LOOKING AT THE OUTSIDE.
YOU HAVE TO OPEN IT UP TO FIND
OUT WHAT'S SO SPECIAL ABOUT IT.
SO, BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE
IN THE PRODUCT ENOUGH, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
YOU GUYS GOT TWO OFFERS.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
UM...CAN I CONFER WITH NED
FOR A MINUTE?
OF COURSE.
[ INDISTINCT CONVERSATION ]
OKAY.
WELL, WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
LORI AND ROBERT FOR THE OFFER.
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT
KEVIN'S OFFER.
WOW. MIRACLES HAPPEN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
O'Leary: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SMART MOVE. I'D NEVER SAY
IT'S A SMART MOVE WHEN
YOU'RE IN BUSINESS WITH KEVIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH,
REALLY.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
IT STILL AMAZES ME WHEN ANYBODY
DOES A DEAL WITH YOU, KEVIN.
IT IS SHOCKING.
REALLY IS SHOCKING.
ROBERT,
YOU TABLED AN INFERIOR DEAL
BECAUSE YOU'VE
NO CREATIVITY.
YOU KNOW, I'M GIVING
ALL MY TRADE SECRETS AWAY
TO YOUR SHARKS.
IT'S JUST SCARY.
Jen:
WE TOOK KEVIN'S OFFER TODAY
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
IN OUR COMPANY,
WE BELIEVE
THAT IT'S GONNA GROW,
IT'S GONNA BE THE STANDARD,
SO WE DID NOT WANT TO GIVE UP
THAT MUCH OF A STAKE.
Narrator: IN SEASON 5,
BRIAN AND JULIE WHITEMAN
MADE A DEAL WITH KEVIN O'LEARY
FOR THEIR SUBSCRIPTION
PHOTO-PRINTING SERVICE,
GrooveBook.
CHOOSE UP TO 100 PHOTOS
EVERY MONTH FROM YOUR SMARTPHONE
AND CREATE A BEAUTIFUL, BOUND
PHOTO BOOK IN JUST MINUTES.
LET'S SEE
HOW THEY'RE DOING NOW.
Julie: SINCE MAKING OUR DEAL
ON "SHARK TANK,"
OUR BUSINESS
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE.
OUR SUBSCRIBER BASE
HAS GROWN 15 TIMES
SINCE THE DAY
WE AIRED ON "SHARK TANK."
OKAY, LET'S DO THIS.
O'Leary:
I'M HERE IN NEW YORK CITY
WITH BRIAN AND JULIE
FROM GrooveBook.
I ALWAYS KNEW SOMETHING HUGE WAS
GONNA HAPPEN WITH THIS COMPANY,
AND TODAY IS THE DAY
IT ALL COMES TOGETHER.
KEVIN,
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE'RE MEETING WITH SHUTTERFLY,
THE MARKET LEADER
IN PERSONALIZED,
DIGITAL-PHOTO PRODUCTS.
SHUTTERFLY DOES
OVER $900 MILLION IN REVENUE.
THEY'VE GOT
TENS OF MILLIONS OF USERS,
AND GrooveBook HAS
A FANTASTIC PRODUCT.
IT'S A PERFECT MARRIAGE.
WE'D LIKE TO MAKE
A FINAL OFFER
IN THE AMOUNT
OF $14.5 MILLION.
WOW.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
THE GrooveBook BRAND
HAS GROWN IN WAYS
WE COULD HAVE
NEVER IMAGINED,
AND TODAY,
WE'RE FINALLY READY TO SELL.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S DO IT.
LET'S DO IT.
Brian: WHEN WE PITCHED
ON "SHARK TANK,"
WE BARELY HAD ANY SALES.
AND TODAY,
A YEAR AFTER OUR DEAL,
WE'RE SELLING GrooveBook
FOR $14.5 MILLION.
Housenbold: ALL RIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE GrooveBook DEAL
IS THE LARGEST DEAL EVER
IN "SHARK TANK" HISTORY.
IT'S A DREAM COME TRUE, AND
I FEEL WARM AND FUZZY INSIDE.
AND I'M HERE NOW
WITH SHARK KEVIN O'LEARY.
I GUESS I SHOULD SAY
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU SAW THIS ONE EARLY.
WE JUST CLOSED THE BIGGEST DEAL
IN "SHARK TANK" HISTORY,
AND I'M HERE ON THE SET
OF "GOOD MORNING AMERICA"
TO TELL THE WHOLE WORLD
ABOUT IT.
EVEN YOU COULDN'T HAVE PREDICTED
THIS KIND OF BREAKOUT SUCCESS.
NO, BUT IT TAUGHT ALL OF US
WHAT A PLATFORM "SHARK TANK" IS.
THIS YOUNG FAMILY
HAS JUST PROVEN
THE AMERICAN DREAM
IS STILL ALIVE.
THIS HAS REALLY BEEN
LIFE-CHANGING FOR OUR FAMILY,
AND WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FORWARD
TO SPENDING TIME WITH THEM
AND TRAVELING THE WORLD.
IT JUST SHOWS
YOU SHOULD NEVER GIVE UP
AND PURSUE YOUR DREAMS.
Narrator: NEXT UP IS
WHAT THE ENTREPRENEUR BELIEVES
IS A GAME CHANGER
IN REAL-ESTATE INVESTING.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS AARON McDANIEL,
FROM SAN FRANCISCO, CALIFORNIA,
AND I'M THE C.E.O.
OF TYCOON REAL ESTATE.
I'M SEEKING $50,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR 5% OF MY COMPANY.
FOR LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF YEARS,
THE MOST PROVEN WAY
TO CONSISTENTLY BUILD WEALTH
HAS BEEN THROUGH INVESTING
IN REAL ESTATE.
UNFORTUNATELY, TRADITIONAL
REAL-ESTATE INVESTING
IS DIFFICULT, INTIMIDATING,
AND EXPENSIVE.
THE BEST DEALS ARE ONLY OFFERED
TO THE SUPERWEALTHY
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS,
HELPING THE RICH GET RICHER
AND LOCKING
THE REST OF US OUT.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT?
[ LAUGHS ]
NOW YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET IN ON THE GROUND FLOOR
OF AN EXCITING, NEW BUSINESS
THAT WILL CHANGE
REAL-ESTATE INVESTING FOREVER.
TYCOON REAL ESTATE
IS A CROWD-INVESTING PLATFORM
THAT ALLOWS EVERYDAY PEOPLE
TO INVEST IN REAL ESTATE
FOR AS LITTLE AS $1,000.
I HATE IT. I'M OUT.
Corcoran: WOW.
I SMELL JAIL TIME.
WOW, MARK.
THAT'S AGGRESSIVE.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, BARBARA?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I HAVEN'T EVEN FORMED
AN OPINION. KEEP GOING.
SURE, YEAH. LET ME --
LET ME GO AHEAD AND FINISH MY --
DON'T LET THAT
UNSETTLE YOU.
SO, ALL OF OUR DEALS
ARE PROFESSIONALLY VETTED,
ONLY WORKING
WITH TOP DEVELOPERS.
AND IF THE FUNDING GOAL IS NOT
MET FOR A CERTAIN PROJECT,
EVERYONE
GETS THEIR MONEY BACK.
SO NOW YOU CAN GET 8 TO 10 TIMES
THE RETURN YOU COULD GET,
COMPARED TO KEEPING YOUR MONEY
IN A SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
SO, LET ME --
LET ME TALK YOU THROUGH
A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW IT WORKS.
SO, FIRST,
WE GO TO TYCOON'S WEBSITE.
ONCE YOU'RE HERE,
YOU CAN LOOK THROUGH
OUR LIST
OF INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT TYPES
FROM RESIDENTIAL TO COMMERCIAL,
EACH WITH THEIR OWN
UNIQUE INVESTMENT OBJECTIVES.
SO, AS AN EXAMPLE, THIS ONE HERE
IS A MARQUEE RETAIL PROPERTY
THAT'S PART OF A LARGE
COMMERCIAL COMPLEX
JUST OUTSIDE
OF THE MANHATTAN AREA.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS ENTER THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
YOU'D LIKE TO INVEST,
GO THROUGH
A SIMPLE ONLINE PROCESS,
AND ONCE
THE INVESTMENT GOAL IS MET,
YOU'RE A REAL-ESTATE INVESTOR.
THEN YOU CAN SIT BACK
AND ENJOY THE PROFITS YOU GET
FROM THE APPRECIATION AND
THE CASH FLOWS OF THE PROPERTY.
SO, SHARKS, WE'RE ON THE BRINK
OF AN EXCITING, NEW ERA
WHERE LITERALLY ANYONE
CAN BE A REAL-ESTATE TYCOON.
HOW DO I GET MY MONEY BACK?
HOW DO I GET THE RETURN?
BOOM, BOOM, BOOM!
GIVE THE GUY A CIGAR!
SO, I MEAN, ULTIMATELY,
THIS IS --
THIS IS A BUSINESS TO SCALE
IN A BIG WAY.
BUT WALK ME THROUGH
A SINGLE MODEL.
SURE.
I INVEST IN THAT BUILDING
IN NEW JERSEY.
I GIVE YOU $10,000.
SURE.
I ASSUME I OWN
SOME PERCENTAGE OF IT.
THAT'S CORRECT.
I ASSUME THAT BUILDING
IS TAKING ON SO MUCH RENT,
I'M MAKING MONEY.
YES.
THEN THE BUILDING
GETS SOLD ONE DAY.
MM-HMM.
I'M ASSUMING I MAKE A RETURN
ON MY $10,000
EQUAL TO MY VALUE
OF THE OVERALL BUILDING.
RIGHT, SO DEPENDING ON --
WHO SETS THE VALUE
OF THE BUILDING
AT THE TIME
THAT I INVEST?
THE -- WHAT WE REFER TO
AS THE DEAL MAKER --
THE DEVELOPER WHO IS LOOKING
TO RAISE MONEY FOR THE PROJECT.
SO, THERE IS
A LEAD DEVELOPER
THAT IS IN CHARGE
OF THE INVESTMENT?
THAT'S CORRECT.
ARE YOU TAKING A FEE?
SO, WHAT WE TAKE
IS A MANAGEMENT FEE,
A TECHNOLOGY FEE,
SERVICE FEE.
HOW MUCH IS THAT?
HOW ABOUT -- WHAT'S --
1.25%
OF THE AMOUNT RAISED.
HOW MANY
EXISTING BUILDINGS
HAVE YOU ACTUALLY FUNDED
THIS WAY?
ANSWER BARB'S QUESTION.
YEAH, I'M SORRY, BARBARA.
'CAUSE SHE IS
THE REAL-ESTATE MAVEN.
WE'VE DONE
TWO PROOF-OF-CONCEPT DEALS.
FIRST,
WAS A TOTALLY CLOSED DEAL.
AND WHAT WAS THE TOTAL RAISED
ON THAT DEAL?
THAT WAS $100,000.
WHAT WAS IT,
A GARAGE SPACE?
IT WAS A -- IT WAS A --
IT WAS A -- IT WAS A PART
OF A HOUSE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
PART OF A HOUSE?
IT WAS --
IT WAS A PORTION OF THE --
OF THE DEBT POSITION
IN A HOUSE.
AND YOU CHARGED 1.25%
FOR THAT DEAL?
UH, YES.
LET'S SAY I WANT TO INVEST
IN REAL ESTATE.
I CAN GO ONLINE
TO ONE OF THE BIG PLAYERS --
FIDELITY OR SCHWAB --
I CAN BUY A REIT.
A REIT IS A REAL-ESTATE
INVESTMENT TRUST...
MM-HMM.
...SO THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
DIVERSIFICATION IN REAL ESTATE.
TOTAL LIQUIDITY.
I CAN BUY AND SELL IT
ANY DAY I WANT.
I'M GONNA
GET MY YIELD OF 4.5%.
MM-HMM.
AND I HAVE 5,000 PROPERTIES
INSIDE THE REITs.
REITs AREN'T SEXY.
NOBODY BRAGS ABOUT REITs.
THAT'S SO HORRIBLE.
THAT IS SO HORRIBLE.
Herjavec: BUT, AARON,
WHO CARES ABOUT SEXY
WHEN IT COMES
TO SAVING MONEY?
THAT IS SO HORRIBLE.
BECAU--
BECAUSE YOU TALK TO ANY --
THAT IS WRONG
IN SO MANY WAYS.
YOU TALK TO
ANY REAL-ESTATE INVESTOR,
AND ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
THEY TALK ABOUT INVESTING
IS THAT PHYSICAL,
EMOTIONAL CONNECTION
THEY HAVE TO THE BUILDING.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE A PHYSICAL
AND EMOTIONAL CONNECTION
TO THEIR LIFE SAVINGS.
I LOVE INVESTING
IN REAL ESTATE,
BUT I RECOGNIZE
IT'S PURE LUCK.
I-I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S TRUE.
IF YOU CAN BUY
ALMOST ANY PIECE OF REAL ESTATE,
YOU WILL MAKE MONEY
OVER 10 YEARS.
MM-HMM.
IF, DURING THAT TIME,
YOU NEED LIQUIDITY,
YOU MAY LOSE
A LOT OF MONEY.
I THINK WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
PEOPLE'S LIFE SAVINGS --
MM-HMM.
...AND I THINK THIS ATTRACTS
THE KIND OF PERSON
WHO WANTS A GREATER RETURN
FOR THEIR RETIREMENT --
I THINK YOU GOT TO BE
CONSERVATIVE WITH YOUR MONEY.
BE RISKY AT WORK,
BE SAFE WITH YOUR INVESTMENTS.
A-AND TO THAT POINT,
T-THERE -- THERE'S AN --
I'M OUT. I'M OUT.
OKAY.
AND T-THERE -- AND THERE --
THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF CONSERVATIVE INVESTMENTS
YOU CAN ALSO GO FOR.
THIS IS NOT
A CONSERVATIVE INVESTMENT.
PLATFORMS LIKE THIS CAN ACTUALLY
HELP STANDARDIZE THINGS,
PROTECT INVESTORS SO THAT
THEY CAN FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE.
PROTECT INVESTORS?
THAT'S -- THAT'S --
THAT'S CORRECT.
THE REASON I WENT OUT --
AND THIS IS THE SAME PROBLEM
WITH A LOT OF
CROWDFUNDING-BASED INVESTMENTS,
NOT JUST REAL ESTATE,
RIGHT?
SURE.
WHEN GRANDMA
HEARS ABOUT CROWDFUNDING
AND HOW ALL THESE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES ARE NOW AVAILABLE
TO NORMAL AMERICANS WHO WANT
TO TOUCH AND FEEL REAL ESTATE,
THEY PUT THEIR LAST $1,000 IN,
THEIR FIRST $1,000 --
DOESN'T MATTER
HOW MUCH THEY HAVE LEFT.
YEAH.
BUT SOMEBODY GETS SICK.
GRANDMA GETS SICK.
YOU KNOW, CAR BREAKS DOWN,
WHATEVER IT IS.
THEY NEED LIQUIDITY.
YES.
THEY HAVE NONE.
THE WAY THAT THE RULES ARE
OUTLINED IS THAT AFTER A YEAR
OF HOLDING A CROWDFUNDED
EQUITY INVESTMENT,
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO SELL IT.
YEAH, TO WHO?
THAT'S -- IT'S -- T-THIS IS
ONE OF THE MARKET RISKS.
EXACTLY.
LET ME JUST JUMP IN
FOR A MINUTE.
I DON'T LIKE THE IDEA
OF INVESTING IN REAL ESTATE
ONLINE WITH A BUNCH
OF OTHER PEOPLE I DON'T KNOW.
THAT SEEMS, TO ME,
RISKY AND UNCOMFORTABLE.
AND FOR THAT SIMPLE REASON,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I THINK THE ACHILLES' HEEL
IN THIS --
AND IT COMES FROM YEARS
OF INVESTING IN REAL ESTATE --
IS YOUR LEAD INVESTOR.
WHO IS THE LEAD INVESTOR?
HOW SMART ARE THEY?
HOW DO THEY
WORK THE ANGLES?
WHAT KIND OF FINANCING
DO THEY PROVIDE?
AND I BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S THE KEY
TO ANY GREAT
REAL-ESTATE INVESTMENT.
MM-HMM.
THIS IS
A MYSTERY INVESTOR HERE.
HOW DO I KNOW
HE'S GOT A GOOD EYE?
HOW DO I BELIEVE
HIS PROJECTIONS?
TOO SPOOKY
AND, FRANKLY, UNFAIR
TO SOMEONE
WHO ISN'T WELL-INFORMED
IN THE REAL-ESTATE BUSINESS
AND EXPERIENCED.
THAT'S RIGHT,
AND THAT'S WHY WE DO THE VETTING
TO MAKE SURE WE ONLY WORK WITH
TOP PEOPLE.
YOU'VE GOT TO TRUST THE OPINION
OF WHO'S BEHIND IT,
AND THAT'S WHAT'S SCARY, AND
THAT'S WHY I'M DEFINITELY OUT.
OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CRIMINAL RECORD
WHATSOEVER?
[ CORCORAN LAUGHS ]
NO. NO, I DON'T.
YOU'RE IN MY SPACE.
I'M IN FINANCIAL SERVICES.
YEP. I-I KNOW YOU HAVE
A MORTGAGE COMPANY YOU STARTED.
I KNOW
WHAT THE BURDEN IS...
MM-HMM.
...TO BE THE STEWARD
OF PEOPLE'S MONEY.
I HAVE $1 BILLION OF IT
WITH MY NAME ON IT.
MM-HMM.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
MY INVESTORS DON'T LOSE MONEY.
YOU HAVE SOMETHING HERE
THAT SOUNDS INTERESTING TO ME,
AND SO, HERE, I'M GONNA TELL YOU
WHAT I WANT TO DO WITH YOU.
THERE'S GOING TO BE THOUSANDS OF
SITES LIKE TYCOON THAT EMERGE.
MM-HMM.
THEY HAVE NO BRAND.
JUST THINK OF THE NAME, TYCOON!
TYCOON!
I KNOW.
PLEASE. LET ME FINISH.
TYCOON -- WHAT DOES THAT SAY
TO A SMALL INVESTOR?
IT'S A RIP-OFF NAME.
WHEN I STARTED IN 2008
AND CREATED O'LEARY FUNDS,
I HAD NO DOLLARS.
NOW I HAVE $1 BILLION.
MM-HMM.
THE ONLY REASON THAT HAPPENED IS
I HAD A BRAND.
PEOPLE TRUSTED ME.
MAYBE I'M A TOUGH GUY,
BUT I MAKE PEOPLE MONEY
AND I PROTECT THEIR CAPITAL.
MM-HMM.
WHY? 'CAUSE I PUT MY OWN MONEY
IN EVERY DEAL,
AND I CARE A LOT
ABOUT MY OWN MONEY -- A LOT.
YES.
OKAY?
SO, YOU HAVE NO BRAND.
TYCOON MEANS NOTHING TO ANYBODY.
I DO HAVE A BRAND, AND I HAVE
A TRACK RECORD OF SUCCESS.
MM-HMM.
I'LL GIVE YOU $50,000,
AND I WANT 50%.
I'M GONNA
REBRAND THIS THING.
Herjavec: HE'S MADE YOU
A LEGITIMATE OFFER.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
WE ALL MAKE FUN OF KEVIN,
BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THIS --
HE REALLY DOES CARE
ABOUT HIS MONEY.
I WOULDN'T GO ANYWHERE HIGHER
THAN 10% WITH THAT.
BUMMER.
YOU THINK
I'M GONNA PUT MY NAME --
HE DOESN'T WANT
YOUR NAME.
I-I-I'M NOT ASKING
FOR YOUR NAME. THIS IS --
BUT YOU HAVE NOTHING!
CORRECT.
I HAVE A PROVEN MODEL
THAT RAISED $1 BILLION
IN 36 MONTHS -- MY NAME.
GOT TO DECIDE, AARON.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
NO, SO...
HE'S SAYING NO.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
I FORGOT YOUR NAME ALREADY.
I'M OUT.
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
THANK YOU.
THE SHARKS DIDN'T GET IT
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
TYCOON REAL ESTATE
IS NOT A SLEAZY COMPANY
LOOKING TO SWINDLE MONEY
OUT OF ANYONE.
WE'RE LOOKING TO HELP PEOPLE
INVEST IN REAL ESTATE
AND GIVE THEM A NEW OPPORTUNITY
THAT THEY NEVER
COULD HAVE HAD BEFORE.
ROBERT, AFTER SIX YEARS
IN THE SHARK TANK WITH YOU,
I'M VERY TOUCHED.
YOU SAID SOMETHING NICE
ABOUT ME,
AND YOU REALLY DISCOVERED
WHO I AM.
[ LAUGHS ]
I REALLY DO LOVE MY MONEY.
AND NEXT TIME YOU GET IN A BOAT
WITH A RAT AND SOME RICE,
I'LL JOIN YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I NEARLY TEARED UP.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT
DESIGNED TO SANITIZE
SOMETHING WE USE EVERY DAY.
HI. I'M DAN BARNES.
AND I'M HIS COUSIN WES LaPORTE,
AND WE'RE FROM PROVO, UTAH.
OUR COMPANY IS PHONESOAP,
AND WE'RE SEEKING $300,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 7.5%
OF OUR COMPANY.
IT ALL STARTED
WITH A QUESTION --
WHAT'S DIRTIER -- YOUR CELLPHONE
OR A PUBLIC TOILET?
A PUBLIC TOILET, RIGHT?
WRONG.
IT'S YOUR PERSONAL CELLPHONE.
IN FACT,
THE AVERAGE CELLPHONE
HAS 18 TIMES
MORE HARMFUL BACTERIA
THAN ANY SURFACE
IN A PUBLIC RESTROOM,
AND ONE IN SIX PHONES
WAS FOUND WITH FECAL MATTER.
DISGUSTING.
SO, WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED
TO DO -- STOP TOILET TEXTING?
NO, DAN, YOU USE
PHONESOAP CHARGER.
PHONESOAP CHARGER
USES ULTRAVIOLET LIGHT
TO KILL ALL THE BACTERIA ON
YOUR PHONE IN JUST FIVE MINUTES.
AND IT'S UNIVERSAL,
SO IT CLEANS ANY PHONE
AND IT CHARGES ANY PHONE.
SO, HOW DO OUR PHONES GET
SO DIRTY IN THE FIRST PLACE?
WELL, YOU SEE, WHAT OUR HANDS
TOUCH, OUR PHONES TOUCH.
AND WHILE WE WASH OUR HANDS
TO KEEP HEALTHY,
WE NEVER WASH
OUR PHONES.
THAT'S WHY PHONESOAP'S
THE PERFECT SOLUTION
TO THIS "GROWING" PROBLEM.
IT KILLS 99.999%
OF ALL BACTERIA
AND CAN FIT AND CLEAN
EVEN THE LARGE PHONES.
SHARKS,
WE DON'T EXPECT YOU
TO CEASE ALL
COMMODE COMMUNICATION...
[ LAUGHS ]
...BUT WE DO NEED
YOUR HELP
TO START
A CLEAN-PHONE REVOLUTION.
AMEN, DANIEL.
[ HERJAVEC LAUGHS ]
DO WE GET TO SEE SAMPLES?
I'LL BRING ONE RIGHT UP.
WHY WOULDN'T
I JUST USE SANITIZER?
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THANK YOU.
SO, ALCOHOL, OBVIOUSLY,
KILLS BACTERIA,
BUT IT REALLY DOES
TWO THINGS.
IT CAN DAMAGE THE PHONE
AND VOID THE WARRANTY.
OH, THAT IS
A HORRIBLE RESPONSE.
CAN YOU USE A SANITIZER
ON A TYPICAL CELLPHONE?
YES! OF COURSE, YOU CAN.
WELL, HERE'S
THE REASON WHY --
HERE'S THE REASON
WHY YOU DON'T WANT TO,
IS BECAUSE THERE'S
AN OLEOPHOBIC COATING
THAT SHIPS
WITH ALL YOUR PHONES.
AND IF YOU USE
A CHEMICAL CLEANER ON IT,
IT STRIPS THAT COATING,
SO YOUR FINGERPRINTS STICK
TO THE SCREEN MORE.
LOOK, FOR THAT VALUATION,
YOU MUST HAVE SOME SALES, RIGHT?
YEAH, SO, WE'VE SOLD,
IN THE LAST 5 1/2 MONTHS,
$537,000 IN SALES.
YOU HAVE?
HOW MUCH DO
EACH ONE OF THESE COST?
$59.95.
SO, YOU SELL IT FOR $59.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU TO MAKE?
IT COSTS US $20
TO MAKE IT.
OKAY, WHERE
ARE YOU SELLING THIS?
WE STARTED MOSTLY ONLINE,
AND WE'VE GOT A LARGE
OFFICE-SUPPLY COMPANY, STAPLES.
OH, YOU HAVE IT
IN STAPLES.
HOW MANY STORES
IN STAPLES?
WE'RE IN 400 STORES.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND,
GUYS?
WE STARTED THIS, ACTUALLY,
IN COLLEGE. WE'RE COUSINS.
AT THE TIME, I WAS DOING
CANCER RESEARCH IN A LAB,
AND DAN TOLD ME ABOUT
THIS ARTICLE HE READ
THAT OUR PHONES ARE 18 TIMES
DIRTIER THAN A PUBLIC RESTROOM.
I SWABBED ALL THESE
DIFFERENT SURFACES
AND FOUND THAT, YEAH,
MY PHONE REALLY IS THAT DIRTY.
WE USE ULTRAVIOLET LIGHTS
IN THE LAB TO SANITIZE SURFACES,
SO WE TOOK THAT TECHNOLOGY,
MARRIED IT TO A CHARGER
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
ALREADY CHARGING YOUR PHONE,
YOU MIGHT AS WELL CLEAN IT
AT THE SAME TIME.
SO THERE'S --
I'M GONNA GUESS THAT THERE'S
NO PATENT YOU CAN GET ON THIS
'CAUSE CLEANING DEVICES
OF THIS KIND ARE EVERYWHERE.
SO, WE ACTUALLY HAVE
TWO UTILITY PATENTS SUBMITTED.
I BET YOU
OUR AVERAGE PHONE HERE,
IF YOU SWABBED IT,
WOULD BE DISGUSTING.
THE AVERAGE CONSUMER
IS RELATIVELY LAZY,
AND I'M NOT SURE THEY SEE THIS
AS A MAJOR ISSUE
THAT THEY ARE WILLING
TO SPEND MONEY ON.
YEAH, ROBERT,
I THINK IT'S A BIGGER ISSUE.
BECAUSE OUR PHONES
ARE PORTABLE,
OUR CHARGING DEVICES
HAVE ALSO BECOME VERY PORTABLE.
WELL, WE -- WE'VE SEEN
A LOT OF OUR CUSTOMERS
PUT IT IN THEIR OFFICE --
LIKE, AT THEIR DESK,
AND WHAT WE FOUND IS
MOST PEOPLE ARE GONNA PAY
30 BUCKS FOR A CHARGER
OR A CASE.
NO!
AND THEY LOOK FORWARD
TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE --
OH, 30 BUCKS?
YOU GOT TO CONVINCE PEOPLE
THAT THEIR PHONE IS A CESSPOOL.
AND YOU HAVE TO
CONVINCE THEM
NOT TO USE PURELL
AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
I'M STRUGGLING 'CAUSE
YOU'VE SOLD HALF A MILLION,
SO MAYBE I'M WRONG.
MAYBE YOU'VE FOUND
A SEGMENT OF THE MARKET
THAT'S REALLY ANAL ABOUT THIS.
SO, WE'VE SPENT
A LOT OF MONEY
TO DO FOCUSED
AND TARGETED MARKETING,
SO WE'RE STARTING FIRST
WITH THE --
HOW MUCH MONEY
HAVE YOU SPENT?
THIS YEAR, WE'VE SPENT
ABOUT $80,000 IN MARKETING.
WOW.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU RAISED
IN TOTAL?
WE'VE RAISED $800,000,
SO --
Cuban: OH!
$800,000?
ON KICKSTARTER?
Barnes:
IT WAS FROM A LOCAL INVESTOR.
WE GAVE UP
60% OF OUR COMPANY.
60%?
SO, THE QUESTION
IS WHY?
YES.
WE WERE
TWO ENTREPRENEURS
THAT REALLY HAD AN IDEA
THAT WE LOVED.
WE HIT THE POINT
WHERE IT WAS LIKE,
"IT'S GONNA COST US
A LOT OF MONEY TO MAKE IT,"
AND WE DECIDED IT WAS EITHER BE
GREEDY AND HAVE THIS GO NOWHERE
OR GIVE OURSELVES
AN OPPORTUNITY --
Cuban: OH, THAT'S FAIR ENOUGH.
THAT'S FAIR ENOUGH.
THE PROBLEM IS
UNLESS YOU GET THAT P.R. POP,
IT'S GONNA BE VERY,
VERY EXPENSIVE TO SUSTAIN.
SO, YOUR SALES
PROBABLY GO LIKE THIS, RIGHT?
IT'S A NICHE PRODUCT.
YOU-YOU'RE NOT
A COMPANY YET.
RIGHT.
ONE THING WE'VE UNCOVERED
IS THAT THERE'S A HUGE MARKET
IN HOSPITAL AND SCHOOLS.
BUT, GUYS,
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF SANITIZERS
THAT HOSPITALS USE
FOR THEIR DEVICES.
THERE'S A WHOLE PROTOCOL
THAT THEY GO THROUGH.
SURE. WELL, HOSPITALS HAVE
STARTED REACHING OUT TO US
TO COME
PRESENT THE PRODUCT,
AND IT'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE STARTING TO DEPLOY
LOTS OF TABLETS
INTO THE HOSPITALS.
THEY USE THEM
WHEN THEY GO INTO THE ROOM.
WES, I GOT TO TELL YOU, I...
[ SIGHS ]
I DON'T SEE IT.
I DON'T NEED A TANNING BED
FOR MY PHONE.
I'M OUT.
OKAY, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE HOSPITAL APPLICATION.
WHAT'S THE LOWEST COST
YOU CAN GET,
AND CAN YOU GET IT SO IT CLEANS
IN UNDER A MINUTE?
YEAH, THERE'S THREE PARAMETERS
THAT YOU NEED
FOR EFFECTIVE U.V. KILLING.
ONE OF THE THEM
IS THE PROXIMITY.
THE FURTHER AWAY
YOU MOVE THE LIGHT
FROM THE SURFACE,
IT DECREASES.
ALSO THE INTENSITY
AND THE DURATION.
AND SO YOU CAN PLAY WITH
THOSE THREE FACTORS,
AND IF YOU CAN GET THE LIGHT
CLOSE ENOUGH
AT THE RIGHT INTENSITY,
THEN YOU CAN REDUCE THE TIME.
NOW YOU'VE GOT
MY INTEREST, RIGHT?
A PRODUCT FOR CONSUMER
FOR PHONESOAP -- PBHT!
BUT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
WHO GOES TO VISIT
ANYBODY IN THE HOSPITAL
BRINGS THEIR PHONE.
RIGHT.
THAT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT
SELLING PROCESS.
IT IS A DIFFERENT
I'VE INVESTED IN COMPANIES
THAT SELL TO HOSPITALS.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA
HOW LONG --
YES, I DO. YES, I DO.
'CAUSE I'VE GOT COMPANIES
THAT SELL TO HOSPITALS, AS WELL.
THAT IS BRUTAL.
FORGET HOSPITALS.
I CAN GO TO ANYBODY WHO PROVIDES
ANY TYPE OF HEALTH SERVICE
AND SAY, SIGN UP THERE,
"PLEASE CLEAN YOUR PHONE.
PUT IT IN HERE," SLAM IT,
ONE MINUTE, BOOM, AND I'M --
WESLEY AND DAN, I THINK MARK
IS EXTREMELY OPTIMISTIC.
I THINK
TEACHING ANY ADMINISTRATION
TO START A NEW HABIT, ASK
THE VISITOR TO PUT THE PHONE IN,
I THINK YOU'RE DREAMING.
HERE'S MY OBJECTION TO IT.
AS A SANITIZER,
IT'S EASY TO USE A BABY WIPE.
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
BABY WIPE -- DONE.
THROW IT AWAY.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
IT'S NOT PORTABLE.
I THINK EVERYBODY TRAVELS
WITH THEIR CHARGER TODAY.
THIS IS TOO BULKY
TO TRAVEL WITH.
RIGHT.
AND SO, FOR ALL OF THOSE
REASONS, I'M OUT.
O'Leary:
I DON'T THINK IT'S BEEN PROVEN
YET AS A SUCCESSFUL PRODUCT,
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE MARKET
IS REALLY ANAL ENOUGH
TO BUY THIS
AND WHAT THE CUSTOMER-
ACQUISITION COST IS GONNA BE.
THE ONLY WAY I DO THIS DEAL --
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU THIS OFFER --
HERE'S HOW IT'S GONNA WORK.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $300,000.
I WANT $6 A UNIT
UNTIL I RECOUP THE $300,000.
AFTER THAT, IT DROPS TO $3 UNTIL
I GET PAID OUT $1.2 MILLION,
AND THEN I GO AWAY.
IT'S -- IT'S A PURE
VENTURE-DEBT STRATEGY.
I THINK IT'S FAIR.
IT'S SOMETHING.
LET'S SEE IF
YOU YOU CAN DO ANY BETTER.
Cuban: IT'S SOMETHING.
IT'S STILL A RIP-OFF.
WE --
I -- I APPREC--
WELL, APPARENTLY,
THAT'S COMING
FROM SOMEONE
WHO GAVE YOU THIS. ZERO.
Corcoran: YEAH.
I WOULDN'T INSULT YOU
WITH THAT.
LOTS OF ADVICE
THAT'S WORTHLESS.
BY THE WAY, I THINK THE
HOSPITAL MARKET IS INTERESTING,
BUT THE SALES CYCLE IS YEARS,
NOT MONTHS -- YEARS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT OFFER.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
IS SOMEONE TO COME IN
FOR AN EQUITY STAKE
BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN SELLING IT.
THE MARKET
HAS BEEN RESPONDING.
60% OF OUR SALES ARE ONLINE
THROUGH TARGETED MARKETING,
SO PEOPLE
ARE BUYING THIS.
THEY DO LIKE
THIS CONCEPT.
TO ME, THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT EVERYBODY'S GOING TO BUY.
BUT ON THE COMMERCIAL SIDE,
THAT'S INTERESTING TO ME.
ANY MEDICAL FACILITY,
PARTICULARLY IN A WAITING ROOM,
WHERE YOU KNOW EVERYBODY'S
USING THEIR PHONES TO KILL TIME.
BUT FROM A HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONAL'S PERSPECTIVE,
I COULD CARRY ANYTHING BAD
INTO THAT WAITING ROOM,
WHICH COULD THEN BE PICKED UP
AND DISTRIBUTED
THROUGHOUT THE HOSPITAL,
WAITING ROOM, WHATEVER.
THAT'S ENORMOUS VALUE.
BUT YOU CAN'T GIVE UP YOUR PHONE
FOR FIVE MINUTES.
I MADE YOU AN OFFER.
SHOULD I WITHDRAW IT?
UM, WE THINK THAT THE --
THE COMPANY IS, UM,
IS WORTH
WHAT WE ASKED FOR.
OKAY, HOW ABOUT THIS?
I'M OUT.
WOW. BIRD IN THE HAND.
OKAY, I'LL MAKE YOU GUYS
AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $300,000.
YOU'RE A FOOL.
I'M ALWAYS A FOOL,
BUT IT'S MADE ME A LOT OF MONEY.
20%, AND THE CONTINGENCY IS
THAT YOU CAN DELIVER A UNIT
THAT CHARGES IN 30 SECONDS
AND THAT WE CAN PRICE
IN THE AREA OF THE $12 COST.
ALL RIGHT, WES, DAN,
YOU'VE GOT AN OFFER -- $300,000.
YOU HAVE HIS OFFER,
BUT YOU HAVEN'T HEARD MINE.
WELL, REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED
LAST TIME.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
MARK CUBAN
HAS OFFERED $300,000
FOR 20% OF THEIR PHONE-CLEANSING
DEVICE PHONESOAP,
BUT LORI WANTS IN
ON THE ACTION.
Cuban: $300,000.
YOU HAVE HIS OFFER,
BUT YOU HAVEN'T HEARD MINE.
Herjavec: WELL, REMEMBER
WHAT HAPPENED LAST TIME.
SO, I SAW THE "DR. OZ"
THAT WAS TALKING ABOUT
WHAT'S ON THE PHONES, RIGHT?
PRETTY SCARY.
I'VE SOLD MILLIONS
IN CELLPHONE CASES,
AND I'VE SOLD MILLIONS
IN SPONGE SANITIZERS
THAT LOOK KIND OF LIKE YOURS,
SO I GET THAT THIS IS
A GREAT CONCEPT.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE YOU
AN OFFER OF $300,000 AT 15%,
BECAUSE I WANT TO TAKE
THIS UNIT, PUT IT ON QVC,
PUT IT IN MY SHOW,
AND SELL HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN IT LIKE THAT.
IF YOU WANT TO GO CONSUMER,
QVC IS THE DESTINATION.
MORE POWER TO YOU,
RIGHT?
Herjavec:
THROWS YOU UNDER THE BUS.
NO, NOT JUST QVC.
RETAIL -- ALL RETAIL.
IF YOU WANT TO GO RETAIL,
WE ALL HAVE RETAIL CONNECTIONS,
BUT, AGAIN, I SEE THIS MORE
AS A COMMERCIAL PRODUCT.
WHY? BECAUSE WE CAN CONTROL
OUR OWN DESTINY.
INSTEAD OF PUTTING IT
OUT THERE
AND WAITING
FOR THE PHONE TO RING
AND HOPING THAT PEOPLE WALK
INTO STORES --
'CAUSE YOU CAN CHARGE
A PREMIUM FOR IT.
IT SENDS THE MESSAGE
TO EVERYBODY WHO WALKS
INTO THOSE DOCTORS' OFFICES
THAT YOU NEED ONE,
RIGHT?
IT'S VALUABLE,
AND IT WORKS.
THE DOCTOR'S USING IT,
IT MUST BE SMART.
RIGHT.
SO THAT'S WHY I SUG--
I SAY, DO IT ALL, GUYS.
I MEAN,
WHY JUST DO DOCTORS' OFFICES?
BUT IT'S TOUGH TO DO ALL, RIGHT?
IT'S TOUGH TO BE GREAT --
OH, NO, IT'S NOT.
I DO IT ALL THE TIME.
YEAH, BUT, LORI,
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU CREATED A SALES FORCE
THAT WENT OUT
AND SOLD A COMMERCIAL PRODUCT
INTO COMMERCIAL ORGANIZATIONS?
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT I DO.
MARK, I HAVE OVER 500 PRODUCTS
IN 17 YEARS.
RIGHT, AND YOU HAVE THAT
SALES FORCE THAT'S GOING ON,
KNOCKING ON DOORS
ALL THE TIME, LORI.
YOU KNOW WHAT? WE DO.
RIGHT.
WES, WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO?
LORI CAME IN AT 15%,
AND YOU'RE AT 20%.
IS THERE...
Cuban: NO.
YOU'LL BE PART OF OUR ENTOURAGE.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BUILDING A COMPANY
AND JUST SELLING
A PRODUCT.
I WOULDN'T HAVE DONE
$40 MILLION, ALMOST,
IN ALL MY "SHARK TANK" PRODUCTS
IF I DIDN'T HAVE
A GREAT SALES FORCE.
AND THAT SALES FORCE
IS TELEVISION TIME ON QVC.
IT'S NOT, MARK.
IT'S NOT FAIR TO SAY THAT.
WE CAME IN AT 7.5%.
15% IS HALF THE VALUATION.
20% IS EVEN MORE
THAN THAT.
IF WE COULD MEET
HALFWAY...
Cuban: WHAT --
I'LL GO TO 10%
IF YOU TAKE MY OFFER RIGHT NOW.
DEAL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
GREAT.
[ CHUCKLES ] WHOO!
LORI.
WE'RE GONNA CLEAN UP
THE MRSA. [ LAUGHS ]
YES.
I THINK THAT THE CONSUMER'S
GONNA LOVE IT.
WE JUST HAVE TO
EDUCATE THEM.
YEAH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, GUYS.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Corcoran: GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
Greiner: WHEW!
WHEW. BAH!
WE JUST DON'T WANT TO SLOW DOWN
WHERE WE ARE NOW.
AND I THINK MARK'S OFFER
WAS TO KIND OF SLOW DOWN HERE
AND MOVE,
WHEREAS LORI WAS LIKE,
"LET'S KEEP GOING HERE
AND GIVE YOU THE MONEY
TO MOVE HERE."